Donald Trump's Senate impeachment trial is
underway, sort of, but not really.
We actually
dreamed hours and hours of yesterday's proceedings,
which went into the night and it was in a
sense the start of Donald Trump's impeachment
trial.
But I say not really because it was filled
merely with amendment proposals and debates
and subsequent tabling by Republicans of those
amendments by Democrats all about how is impeachment
going to be done.
And one of the big arguments was over to catch
you up, like if you missed everything, if
you missed what, what was it, eight hours,
I don't know how long it went yesterday.
If you missed all of those hours, you really
didn't miss very much.
It was one of the big arguments was Republicans
want to deal with documents and witnesses
after both sides have had 24 hours each to
make their arguments.
And after the a hundred senators have had
16 hours to ask questions of the prosecutors
and the defenders, this would be like in a
criminal trial saying documents it would and
witnesses?
No, no, no.
First we want both sides to make all of their
arguments.
We'll give the jury a chance to deliberate
and come back with questions if they have
any.
And then after all of that is done, we'll
discuss whether any witnesses are going to
testify, including witnesses to the alleged
crimes that are being adjudicated here.
It's a laughing stock, it's a farce.
It's a joke of a trial if you do it that way.
So Democrats ended up in the impossible position
of having to propose amendments to deal with
at least the document piece now or of sitting
back and allowing Republicans to just say
we're going to deal with documents and witnesses
later and implicitly saying that that's okay
by not putting forth amendments to try to
change that.
So Democrats proposed an amendment to subpoena
documents from the white house.
Now they debated that amendment nearly two
hours.
And then of course Republicans have a majority
Republicans voted to table or put off that
decision with a 53 to 47 party line vote saying
we'll deal with documents after the trial.
So then Chuck Schumer stands up the Senate
minority leader and proposes another amendment
this time to subpoena documents from the state
department.
And of course the exact same results.
53 to 47 Republicans say, we already have
a process of marble, marble mouth.
Mitch McConnell stood up and says, we're going
to be dealing with documents and witnesses
after 48 and 1664 hours of, uh, of, of testimony,
our arguments and questions we'll deal with
later.
53 to 47 Republicans table it.
So then Democrats say, we have an amendment.
We want to subpoena chief of staff, Mick Mulvaney
or no.
Next was a documents from the OMB.
And then we want to subpoena Mick Mulvaney.
Then we want to subpoena the documents from
the defense department.
We want to subpoena Robert Blair Mulvaney.
He's a senior advisor.
We want to subpoena Michael Duffy.
The OMB is associate director for national
security.
We want to subpoena national security advisor,
John Bolton.
We'll talk about that later.
And of course, Democrats can't win those amendments
because they don't have the votes, but they
can't just stay silent about this atrocity
being committed by Republicans led by Senate
majority leader Mitch McConnell.
So they have to do the logical and obvious
thing, which is we don't agree with the process.
We don't agree with 64 hours of proceedings
before we debate which documents and witnesses
will be admitted.
So they have no choice but to introduce these
amendments.
Every single one of which was of course tabled
by Republicans.
Eventually senators approved a roadmap for
impeachment for the trial, which Mitch McConnell
laid out.
And again, Democrats don't have the numbers,
but the important parameters are that each
side will have 24 hours to present opening
arguments.
Mitch McConnell wanted each side to have two
days for those 24 hours.
That's 12 hours a day.
That is a Republican strategy to have insanely
late night stuff going on, which way fewer
people would see.
They were able to get Republicans to say,
okay, we can spread the 24 hours over three
days, meaning it won't go as late into the
night.
Uh, any, uh, uh, uh, another sort of compromise
is that subpoenas for witnesses and documents
will be debated after opening arguments.
So understand the insanity of this.
What Republicans wanted was to have 24 hours
of opening arguments from one side, 24 hours
of opening arguments from the other side and
16 hours of questions from senators and then
to debate subpoenas and witnesses, subpoenas
of documents and witnesses.
What they've Democrats want it to do it right
now, which makes sense.
What they've agreed upon is they will do the
48 hours of opening arguments.
Then debate subpoenaing documents and witnesses,
a small concession but a concession nonetheless
and then all of the house evidence, the stuff
that came up during the intelligence and the
judiciary hearings, that will all be automatically
part of the Senate trial unless someone objects
rather than having to introduce bits of evidence
and testimony piece by piece.
Okay.
Only water and milk were allowed into the
Senate chamber.
There was a rule of silence during yesterday's
proceedings which led to senators flashing
almost like flashcards, flashing pieces of
paper with notes on them to other crazy.
So today is day two.
I hope you'll again join me for a live stream
on YouTube and Twitch.
Yesterday's live stream saw nearly a hundred
thousand different people.
Join us over the course of the afternoon and
evening.
We'll be back at it today.
Here's what to watch for today.
Do Donald Trump's lawyers respond with any
substance?
Yesterday, Adam Schiff and the other democratic
impeachment managers, uh, we're talking about
substance and meanwhile, Trump's lawyers,
Pat sip, Aloni and Jay Sekulow talked about
circumstances.
They talked about, we weren't invited to things
that they actually were invited to.
They talked about Joe Biden.
They talked about everything other than the
actual substance of the allegations.
So question one for today is, will they talk
about substance?
I predict no.
Number two today, there's going to be a whole
new round of motions, including more than
likely motions by Republicans to dismiss the
entire case against Donald Trump.
Trump wildly suggested that the entire impeachment
trial should simply be canceled on Twitter
a couple of weeks ago.
And we know that when Donald Trump says jump
Republicans say how high?
And that is likely something they will do
today.
Argue the entire case should just be canceled.
By the time you hear this segment or watch
today's show, we will likely know whether
they've submitted such motions because they're
doing writing before they actually start.
If you are wondering, this seems like a lot
of sidebar.
When will the actual substantive arguments
begin?
We don't know.
It could happen later this week.
Friday could be Saturday.
They do plan to go six days a week.
The substance may not even start until early
next week.
It's going to be very long.
Donald Trump will be acquitted at the end
unless something completely beyond our ability
to predict happens and the most important
message is this one.
Yesterday you had people on both sides, Democrats
and Donald Trump's lawyers arguing that if
this is not a full and fair trial, it's not
good for anyone.
In other words, the argument was if people
don't believe, if the public doesn't believe
that this is a fair trial, an acquittal isn't
very powerful and a conviction isn't very
powerful.
They are wrong.
Given that an acquittal is all but a foregone
conclusion, only half the country really cares
about a fair trial.
This won't be a fair trial.
There may or may not be witnesses.
It will be a sham in which Republicans have
already prejudged and we know they will vote
to acquit, but Trumpus would be fine with
that when they say, unless this is a full
and fair trial.
And acquittal of Donald Trump isn't worth
very much wrong, Trump is, we'll see the eventual
acquittal as an exoneration.
And then they will say, look, Trump did nothing
wrong.
He was exonerated.
So where I completely disagree with what has
been argued from both sides.
Adam Schiff argued this and also Trump's lawyers
argued this, Trump doesn't need a fair trial
for his acquittal to be accepted.
His followers will accept the acquittal as
an exoneration, no matter what kind of a kangaroo
court ends up rendering that verdict.
Let's now focus in on one witness.
Uh, John Bolton.